- I would safely say, yeah,
my bull(beeping) detector
is pretty good by now.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
Telltale signs of an underage person,
typically you get the
person who is very edgy
when they show up and
they really don't know
exactly how things work,
and they're kind of just
anxious for no reason,
and then, of course, they
hesitantly hand your their ID,
and they kind of just sit there and smile.
- Oh, their body language.
Most people are pretty good at lying,
but their body isn't.
- When they're walking up,
they're, uh, here, and no eye contact.
Usually, I find that people
will stand up straight
and they're like, yes, that's me,
and they'll look at the card,
whereas the other one will be like,
hey, yo, and kind of look away,
so I mean, those are
just some of the signs.
(upbeat music)
- There's certain things
on one ID that's real
that you won't find on a fake ID,
and vice versa.
- Some of the things we look for,
when we're looking for a fake ID
would definitely be
laminated pieces of plastic
or pieces of paper that
have absolutely zero traits
of an actual ID.
- Most IDs do have a special actual tag
that you can see in certain lighting.
- Here in California
is if you have a light,
you have the California
bear outlined in the back,
and if you hold it up,
you can see that outline,
whereas the fakes tend to not have it.
(upbeat music)
Well, actually, at my first
job, in 2011, a couple,
either blatantly not
recognizing their surroundings,
or deliberately not caring,
and starting to get it on
while other people are around,
so I had to politely tell them,
"Hey, look, this is not the spot for that.
"I feel you, have a good time.
"Just move it on, take it elsewhere."
- I've seen a lot of people hook up.
Pretty much wherever they can it in,
seen that on, I would
say, an everyday basis.
It's not really crazy anymore.
It's just the norm to me now.
(upbeat music)
- Starting a fight,
and probably stripping,
just getting naked.
- Undermining the fact that we're here,
and we're doing a job, and
we're here to do a job,
and making sure that you're
allowing us to do so.
- Get out of line, and try
to be aggressive with you
for no reason.
It does happen.
You get macho people,
whether it's women or men,
who just have a bad attitude,
and wanna take it out on you.
- Someone not having their
forms of ID like they should,
and just trying to talk me up.
Oh, you're so handsome!
You're so cute!
It's like, um, appreciate the compliment,
but you know, I still
need that form of ID,
if you don't mind.
- Honestly, pet names and things like that
are probably the easiest
way to piss me off.
Oh, things like big boy, big John.
Accurate.
(laughing)
- First impressions,
coming up to the door,
it'll always make a huge statement.
- Being polite.
You actually don't have
to say much to a bouncer.
Just make sure you have your ID card.
- Probably just being
prepared and not having
a bunch of assholes that you're with.
- Don't be getting out of line.
Just have a good time,
and don't be destructive or disruptive
and causing a scene.
(upbeat music)
- The best excuse I've ever gotten
for forgetting an ID was definitely
they said their dog ate it,
which we all know is a crock of shit.
- Literally the worst excuse you could say
is I forgot my ID.
There's no excuses for forgetting it.
Just bring it.
(jazz music)
Most likely not, but
depending on the situation,
every situation is different,
and sometimes, it can be reevaluated
and possibly be let back in,
but in most instances,
if you're escorted out,
you're not coming back in.
(upbeat music)
I would say the bull(beeping)
detector that I have
is pretty on par, and you'd be lucky
if you get away with something.
- I would safely say, yeah,
my bull(beeping) detector
is pretty good by now.
(laughing)
- I'm working on it!
I'm working on it,
but I'd like to think it's pretty good,
probably about a B+, A-,
but that's why we got my
other security officer,
who's here for to help me,
when I may miss a certain thing,
they're here to pick me back up.
(jazz music)
- You could get to the front of the line,
as long as you had a pretty
good standing relationship
with the person that was
actually at the door.
- I plead the 5th on that.
(laughing)
- Any way to get to the front of the line
is if you know the owner.
That would pretty much be the only thing.
Everyone else is treated
the exact same way here.
(upbeat music)
- For me, one of the best parts of the job
is the fact that I get to be around music,
people, I do like to
dance and sing myself,
so being around the environment
is always good for me.
- Getting to meet new people in here,
and having them kind of trust in you
as a security guy, to say they that trust
that you're there to protect them,
you're gonna do the right things.
- Definitely the social
interaction part of it,
making sure that you're
meeting plenty of people
from all around the world,
but also being a part of
keeping them safe, as well.
(upbeat music)